[Music]
all right welcome back
so we're talking about the divergence
the gradient and the curl of
vector fields these are vector calculus
operations and in the last two lectures
i covered the grad and div so today
we're going to talk about the curl
of our vector field
and curl is a really useful quantity it
tells us how much our vector field is
rotating so these were the two vector
fields i looked at in the last lecture
for divergence where this one is
is diverging and this one has divergence
zero
but we noticed if we just look at this
one by eye
this is kind of symmetrically
outsourcing in the radial direction
there's no rotation to this vector field
so what we hope is that this curl
quantity will be zero for this case
and in this vector field which has
divergence zero we notice that our flow
essentially is just rotating objects and
so we would expect that we would have a
non-zero curl for this case
so i'm going to define the curl show you
how to compute it we're going to look at
it for these two examples and we'll
think about some other kind of
applications of the curl in fluid flows
and in things like solid body rotations
of like asteroids and you know
mechanical objects
okay good so the curl of a vector field
is essentially this differential
operator del cross product
and
remember i'm just going to write down
the del operator so del or nabla
whatever this differential operator here
and since we're doing a cross product
i'm actually going to write this in
three
dimensions before i've been usually
doing this in 2d just for simplicity
here i'm going to write this in 3d as
partial partial x
partial partial y and partial partial z
or z
okay that's my dell operator
and we're going to take the cross
product of del with a vector valued
function f so f
bar
is going to be a function that has three
components f1
f2
and f3
and just to be very explicit because
this is a vector-valued function of
three components it's a component of x y
and z these are functions of x y and z x
y and z or z
x y and z
x y and
z
okay so that's my vector valued function
and just like these are two dimensional
vector fields this would be a
three-dimensional vector field it would
describe how vectors are pointing in all
of three space
and this could be a nonlinear function
this f1 f2 and f3 could be non-linear
functions of x y and z so for example i
could have a vector field that does
something here and does something
totally different over here based on
this nonlinear function
and so the curl of f uh the way we write
this is sometimes the curl of f
so
curl of f
is equal to the cross product
of my del operator with my f vector okay
so cross product of this vector with
this vector
and so we would literally do uh the
normal cross product that we're used to
seeing so this is equal to
uh the determinant so i'm just going to
write down like the determinant
of this 3x3 matrix that has an i a j
and a k component so this is how we do
the cross product just remember from
from high school we take the determinant
of the ijk unit vectors the second row
is my first vector which in this case is
del so
partial partial x
partial partial y and partial partial z
or z
and the third component of this curl of
this determinant matrix we're writing
down is my f function here f 1
f 2
and f 3.
and so you can actually compute this and
write this out
if you have these f components you can
compute the determinant of this matrix
and it is a expression that will have an
i a j and a k component
so this is really important
the curl takes in a vector field f f bar
a multi-component vector field
and it spits out another vector field it
will have an i a j and a k component so
it takes in a vector and it outputs a
vector
now that's different than the div and
grad operators so grad takes in a scalar
and returns a vector
div takes in a vector and returns a
scalar
and curl takes in a vector and returns a
vector
and so this is kind of interesting
actually if you think about why these
are the three kind of primitive linear
differential operators that we use for
all of linear partial differential
equations and vector calculus
i think there is some intuitive kind of
reason why we need these three operators
to kind of take me from scalar to vector
from vector to scalar and from vector to
vector okay and i guess there's a fourth
one which is the laplacian operator del
squared which takes me from scalar to
scalar okay so i can kind of go from any
of those quantities
let's do this on an example let's say
that my function f f bar equals
uh i think i have an example here that i
like let's say it equals
x y
minus sine
z or z and one okay so this is my f1 f2
and f3 components
and if you like you can also write this
as you know x y
in the i direction
minus sine z in the j direction plus 1
in the k direction so i want you to be
very comfortable going back and forth
between this i j k coordinate notation
and this kind of column vector notation
these are our equivalent representations
this is usually what physicists use this
is usually kind of what i use applied
math
differential equations notation here but
they're completely equivalent
but because i'm using this notation for
the curl for the determinant of this
this thing i want to show you uh how
simple it is to go back and forth from i
j k to column vectors
okay so we're literally going to compute
this quantity the curl of f for this
very specific f vector here so i'm
literally just going to
swap out
f1 f2 and f3 for these quantities here
which is x y
minus sine
z
and one
okay good
uh and
now we actually just go through the the
kind of algebra of computing this this
determinant so i'm just going to remind
you i'm going to do it kind of quickly
the way we do it is
to compute this determinant i basically
take uh the i component
times the determinant of this 2 by 2
subblock that's kind of opposite it so
that's partial y
partial partial y of 1
minus partial partial z of minus sine z
so in the i component
i have this little subdeterminant which
is zero
minus
minus cosine of z so plus cosine of z
i did that a little quickly but you can
confirm that this determinant is just
cosine of z
then i have okay so that was the first
block plus i direction then i do minus
the j direction so these we always
alternate signs as we go along these uh
these kind of majors so minus in the j
direction
the determinant of the two by two sub
block excluding this column
so that would be partial partial x
of one which is
zero minus partial partial z of x y
which is also zero
so i have zero in the j uh the j
component so there's nothing in the j
direction of this curl
and then again so plus i minus j plus k
we alternate sines plus
in the k direction we have the
determinant of this two by two sub block
so partial partial x of sine z again
that's zero
minus partial partial y of x y is just
minus x
minus
x
and so the
curl of this vector field the curl of
this vector field
is a function
that is uh cos
z in the i direction
minus x in the k direction
and if you like you can write that as a
vector
cos z
0
minus x i'm sorry my pen is squeaky i
know that that drives everyone crazy
uh so really really simple this is how
we compute the curl of any old vector
field you like you can write down any
vector field you want and it's
relatively simple to compute its curl
okay now the interpretation of the curl
is a little more subtle what does this
mean what does it mean to have a curl
that's cos z 0 minus x and i'll talk
about that right now
okay
so
let's let's now compute the curl on
these simpler 2d vector fields okay and
so the way we're going to think about
these 2d vector fields
is essentially we have
f1 f2 and 0.
and so if you have f1 f2 and zero
then all of our curl is going to be uh
in the
k
direction okay and so i'm just going to
kind of like write out what this what
this would be in these cases okay
so let me do this in pink here so if i
want to compute the curl of a 2d uh
f bar like this
i would say that in the eye direction
it is
uh oh my goodness let me think um
yeah i'm sorry it's always in the k
direction
and it's going to be partial
f2
partial f2
partial x
minus partial f1 partial y
minus partial f1
partial y this is the curl in 2d this is
just how you and this is all
uh in the unit normal k direction kind
of going out of the board the z
direction that we haven't plotted here
this is x this is y we assume that this
curl is kind of perpendicular to the
board to be consistent with with this
notation but this is the quantity we
compute so let's actually compute it
here okay so the curl of this vector
field curl
of this particular vector field is
partial
f2 partial x that's partial y partial x
that is zero
minus partial f1 partial y which partial
x partial y is also zero
and so this vector field uh is curl free
so we say that this is curl
free
or
ear irrotational arrow oh my goodness
tatiana probably two t's irrotational oh
my goodness i can't spell
i can't spell at all
irrotational so if the curl of a vector
field is zero
it is curl free or irrotational i think
that's probably uh spelled wrong
and this is an intuitive case okay so
this vector field is just you know kind
of radially sourcing out it's symmetric
and if i have a particle that starts at
some angle it just blasts off in that
same angle forever it never kind of
rotates around in this phase portrait
and so that's kind of the intuition of
what it means to be curl free
if there is no rotational component of
this vector field the vector field is
said to be curl free or irrotational
okay
uh good
and of course there's not two t's in
here um because if i had just a regular
rotational vector field rotate is
spelled with one t rotational good
uh okay
but this vector field down here we have
some reason to think that this is
rotational because again if i start with
a little particle or blob here it
rotates around this vector field we've
kind of seen uh seen that happen
so let's compute the curl of this guy
here
okay so similarly
curl of f bar
is
partial of the second component with
respect to x
minus partial of the first component
with respect to y
so partial of the second component with
respect to x is one
minus
partial of the first component with
respect to y is minus minus one which is
plus one
equals two
so this vector field has a curl of two
or it is it is rotational so this is
a rotational
it is a rotational vector field
and i picked a really easy case where
this vector field was divergence free
and had rotation
this vector field
was rotation free but had a divergence
you can have vector fields that have a
little bit of both that are kind of
swirling and expanding that would be
like an unstable spiral source or i
could have a
vector field that's spiraling in
and so that would be a negative
divergence uh
negative curl kind of situation
okay so this hopefully gives you an idea
of the intuition of what this curl means
intuitively on these vector fields
what else do i want to tell you
okay so this had a
positive curl
because this follows the right hand rule
this vector field is curling with my
right hand where my thumb is sticking in
the positive out of board direction this
is just the convention we've agreed on
this is a positive two curl
if i had a vector field that was going
the other direction
that literally i just said this was um i
guess like
minus x and plus y
then this would be going the other way
and my thumb would be going into the
board that would be a negative 2 that
would be rotating in the negative
direction using the right hand rule so
this is just a convention that we all
agree on i think it's a bit prejudiced
i'm left-handed but i'm forced to live
in a right-handed
uh curl world that's okay just get used
to the the convention here
okay um good so we know how to compute
this thing for generic arbitrary nasty
three component vector fields and we get
our own
curl vector field out so that's kind of
interesting we also know how to compute
it for 2d
vector fields you basically just look at
the kth component and that little two by
two sub block
uh here
now i want to give you a little more
intuition for how you can use this curl
so um
maybe i'll just do it right here
and i'll show you so how we can
interpret curl
for something like a solid body rotation
so this i think of as a fluid flow okay
this vector field is like
the vector field that you would see if
you looked at the gulf of mexico or if
you turned on your faucet in your sink
or in your bathtub you might get uh you
know a vector field on the the bottom
metal pan everything's spreading out
and so you know these are vector fields
that are very intuitive from a fluids
perspective
but what i want to show you is that you
can also think about this for things
like if i have an asteroid that's
rotating in space that also has an
interpretation with the curl okay so
let me just
finish this and show you how that that
situation looks
okay
uh so how do i want to draw this i am
going to draw
a
asteroid or some just object this is
just some three-dimensional object
and it lives in x y z coordinates so
there's some coordinate system
uh x
y
and z or z
and again we're using the right hand
rule notation so that if i curl from x
to y i my thumb sticks up in the z
direction
uh good
and what we're going to do is assume
that this asteroid is spinning about
some axis and i'm going to make it
really easy and say that it's spinning
about the z or z axis
so we're going to define this
w vector to be the vector around which
this object is spinning
and we're going to say that it is
rotating at a rate given by omega and i
know that my w and my omega look
identical
but this little arrow tells you that
this is a vector and this doesn't have
an arrow it's a scalar this is the
angular rate
rotating about this vector w
and in general this vector w could be
pointing any which way you like i'm just
picking it aligned with z because it's
easier for me okay
good
now a physical intuitive interpretation
of curl
is that if i have some point on this
asteroid or inside the asteroid let's
say i have some point
i'm going to call it q
and literally from the origin to q is a
vector so every point in this asteroid
has some vector q from the origin to
that point
then that point is moving at some
velocity because the whole thing is
rotating so this is moving at some
velocity that's kind of you know
perpendicular it's kind of moving in the
direction
tangent to this rotation around this w
axis
so this has some v vector
of motion this cue point
has some v
motion that's induced by this whole
object rotating okay and i'm going to
say that this point q is given by a
radial vector r from the origin so q is
defined as some r vector from the origin
and it is rotating this the the rate of
change of this is another vector uh
v v
and so the physical interpretation of
curl that you've probably all learned in
your physics class or in your calculus
class
is that
this vector v
is equal to my omega vector
cross product with my r vector
so every single point on this asteroid i
define that r vector from the origin to
that point and to figure out what the
velocity of that point is i just take
the curl of my the vector i'm rotating
about
with that vector that defines that
position this is the velocity of every
position r that's rotating about that
axis w
so this is pretty cool this is a useful
interpretation of the curl
where essentially this is the angular
velocity vector so i'm just actually
going to write that so this is the
angular
velocity
vector
okay good uh and so if we have
so now uh let me write if
assume that this this w vector if uh
this w vector is just omega
in the k direction in the z
direction kind of in the z third
component if omega is just rotating at
some constant rate omega in the z
direction
and if we say uh and
r equals
x in the i direction plus y in the j
direction plus z in the k direction
that's just how we specify the x y and z
coordinates of this point q x in the i
direction
i'll take x steps in the i direction
y steps in the j direction and z steps
in the the k direction that defines q
then i can compute this v
by taking the cross product of these two
things
um good and so v
equals the curl of these two objects um
and if i want to do that i'm just going
to leave this as an exercise for you all
you can compute this yourself
you get essentially w cross r
equals
minus omega y
in the i direction
plus omega
x
in the j direction
and this makes sense because if i have
some point that is aligned with this
axis in the in the k direction
that point's actually not moving it has
a zero velocity because it's just kind
of spinning around
its axis it's not actually moving you
know with a with a
non-zero velocity so it makes sense that
this curl if i'm rotating about the z
axis would only have components in the i
and j
coordinates
but this is where it gets really
interesting is that if we take the curl
so this v
object this v is a vector field it is
literally a vector field every point on
this asteroid
now defines a vector of how fast that
point on the asteroid is moving around
as this thing spins
so for every point you know points that
are closer to the axis of rotation are
moving less fast points that are farther
from the axis of rotation are moving
more fast points that are at the very
tips are moving the fastest and that
establishes this vector field
for how this thing is rotating
now you could actually
convert this to radial coordinates to
cylindrical coordinates and you would
find that this is uh does not depend on
theta but it only depends on the radius
from that that axis of rotation so again
something you should do
as an exercise
but it gets really interesting so if i
take the curl of this vector field
so curl of
a v
is equal to i have the i
vector the j vector and the k vector
and i have partial partial x partial
partial y
partial partial z
and now i have you know minus omega y
plus omega x and zero
because that's literally what
you're going to derive as a homework
problem is that this is the the v vector
then the curl of that we can compute
pretty easily
okay so in the i direction partial
partial y of zero is zero partial
partial z of x y is zero
so this is zero in the i direction
similarly in the j direction partial
partial x of zero is
partial partial z of omega y is 0.
so
plus 0 in the j direction
and now in the k direction i have
partial partial x of omega x that's an
omega
minus partial partial y of minus omega y
is another
plus omega
so i get plus 2 omega
in the k direction
and so what this means is that if i have
a solid body rotation
literally the rotation of a solid body
like an asteroid
of angular rate omega
about some axis uh you know like the k
direction or the z axis
the curl of the vector field of all of
those particles is equal to two times
that angular rate about the axis of
rotation
and so if i had been rotating about a
different axis
this would be uh in that direction of
that other other axis okay
so that's a really powerful intuitive
definition of curl is that a positive
constant curl
this is just a constant this is not a
function of x y and z it's a constant in
the k direction
a constant positive curl
is associated with a solid body rotation
literally like all the geometry of this
body doesn't deform or change as it's
rotating
and similarly here
because i had a constant uh
curl in this vector field this also
corresponds to solid solid body rotation
if i have some little blob or some
object in this flow it won't get
deformed as it's moving around it will
keep its shape and just rotate as if it
was a solid body in this fluid flow
so very very useful concept here of
solid body rotation
okay i realize that i'm uh just
massively running out of time here and i
don't want to overload you but a couple
of last things i'll tell you
really important facts
the curl
of
a gradient
always equals zero
so the curl
of the gradient of any f
equals zero for
all
f
very interesting facts so any these are
uh are called potential flow solutions
these potential flow vector fields any
potential flow vector field is
irrotational so the gravitational uh
vector field on earth is a potential
field this is literally the gradient of
the gravitational potential that is an
irrotational vector field things are
just coming in at a constant rate
and if you if you come in at some angle
you'll stay on that approach vector
so the curl of a gradient is always zero
and similarly the divergence of a curl
is always zero
of curl
equals 0.
so the divergence of the curl
of any vector-valued function f
equals 0
again for
all
f
and this is kind of cool if i have a
vector field and i compute its curl
it actually the curl of a vector field
gives me exactly the components of that
vector field that are rotating so if
this vector field had a divergence
component and a curl component if it was
you know swirling
and expanding
the curl would only pull out the
swirling part of that vector field it
would only pull out the rotational part
and it would always have a divergence
free
vector field the curl of any vector
field is always divergence free
so we'll we'll revisit these later maybe
we'll even derive these but i just
wanted to throw these up here very very
important properties of the curl as they
relate to the gradient and the
divergence of a vector field
okay good so now we've covered the
gradient the divergence and the curl
we're ready to start looking at how we
would write down conservation laws
uh you know in a control volume and
starting to derive partial differential
equations
for real physical systems so that's all
coming up soon uh thank you